bon vous m'excuserez pour la miniature
je savais que ça coup de tonnerre dans
le milieu de la tech google a purement
et simplement banni
[Musique]
owen peu plus du tout utiliser les
produits et services google pas dans les
produits actuels ont tous les produits
qui sanctuarise pense pas trop au nord
20 qui va sortir demain alors à laquelle
je l'avais lieu donc aujourd'hui
probablement pour vous là dessus vous
n'avez aucun problème par contre à
l'avenir surtout les prochains modèles
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
il sera strictement impossible que vous
voyez utilisent les services google
gmail google maps le pl ace store
android juste android version open
source pour le reste c'est mort c'est
strictement impossible en tout cas
jusqu'à nouvel ordre alors c'est pas une
toute nouvelle histoire
sipa si vous avez suivi un petit peu
actualité ça fait un moment que trump en
tout cas les usa de trump suspecte
huawei de travail et autres de récupérer
des informations faire de l'espionnage
pour le compte de la chine pour compte
de pékin sauf que pour l'instant il n'y
a eu aucune preuve d'apporter de la part
du gouvernement américain juste des
suspicions déjà la semaine dernière
trump avait interdit aux réseaux de
télécommunications américain de se
fournir en équipements auprès
d'entreprises suspectes en tout cas
suspectés de travailler directement avec
pékin et comme huawei bien évidemment
fourni du matériel que ce soit des
routeurs des antennes
ils sont directement ciblés donc c'est
pas un truc tout nouveau ça fait un
petit moment que ça dure mais on arrive
quand même dans une grosse accélération
sauf que là la maison blanche a placé
huawei sur la liste noire des
entreprises suspecte soupçonnées de
fournir des informations à pékin du coup
les strictement impossible pour moi way
de commercer directement avec toutes les
entreprises américaines bien évidemment
il ya beaucoup d'entreprises américaines
mais la plus grosse celle qui va
impacter son business en termes de
smartphones dans le monde entier hors
chine c'est google ce qui est assez
surprenant là dessus c'est que d'autres
pays à la suite des déclarations de
trump ont eu des doutes des soupçons
notamment la france ait eu le royaume
uni il ya une enquête qui a été fait et
y est absolument rien de probant sauf
que google annoncé dimanche 19 mai
suspendre toute relation avec huawei
alors dans les faits qu'est ce que ça
change ça change en fait que tout ce qui
va être matériel en tout cas purement
hardware au niveau des smartphones au
niveau des tablettes au niveau des pc il
sera strictement impossible de retrouver
des composants de qualcomm venant d'
intel et de tous les fournisseurs de
matériel
américains et là je vous parle de waimes
et ses impacts bien évidemment au nord
rassurez vous si vous avez un smartphone
de huawei ou un smartphone de au nord
vous l'avez déjà acheté vous vous avez
en tout cas en projet d'aller l'acheter
il fonctionnera parfaitement bien vous
aurez les mises à jour logicielles
mais vous serez strictement impossible
d'avoir les mises à jour android y alors
encore moins de basculer sur android ku
et pour les futurs modèles de huawei je
pense notamment aux mails 30 mai 30 pro
qui devrait sortir fin d'année elle là
il y aura pas du tout d'android tel que
vous le connaissez aujourd'hui en terme
de vente pure et dure pour huawei et
pour honor vu qu'ils sont pas présents
sur le marché américain ils vont pas
être impacté directement tout cas sur le
marché us par contre pour tous les
produits qui vont être vendues en inde
en europe en afrique hors chine bien
évidemment c'est une vraie catastrophe
parce que l' os se repose sur android
donc là pour le coup vous coupez
d'android c'est un peu compliqué pour la
chine c'est autre chose parce que pour
la chine les services de google sont
purement est strictement interdite en
chine
ils ont une base android et tout le
reste sont des applications chinoise
donc là tu ça posera pas de problème bon
et maintenant qu'est ce qui peut se
passer dans le premier cas on pourrait
imaginer un retour en grâce de la part
de huawei que huawei négocier
directement avec le gouvernement
américain semble quand même relativement
peu évident je ne suis pas sûr d'une que
huawei ait envie de s'installer autour
de la table avec les américains pour
essayer de trouver une solution
commerciale pour ça à mon avis ça va
être un peu difficile la deuxième
solution c'est que google demande une
autorisation expresse auprès des états
unis pour pouvoir commercer directement
avec huawei ça aussi ça me semble quand
même relativement délicat on peut aussi
imaginer en retour que la chine des
sites de répliquer et de bloquer
purement et simplement d'autres services
et produits américains il y en a déjà
beaucoup un peu bloqué mais pourquoi pas
faire un embargo sur des produits ou des
services américains larnaca dans une
certain degré d' escalade mais bon dans
l'absolu pourquoi pas huawei travaille
déjà depuis quelques années de son côté
s y trouvent une solution anticipé en
tout cas ce problème et travaille sur un
os propres alors est-ce que cet os serez
basé sur un android
qu'on va pouvoir trouver en open source
est ce que c'est un os purement et
simplement développé par aurait bon ça
je sais pas en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que même si huawei vous concocte
un os maison vous n'auriez absolument
pas les services de google donc vous
pourriez pas accédé déjà hop les stores
vous n'auriez pas de service gmail
google maps non parlons pas et je vous
parle même pas de youtube et tout le
reste donc bon même si toutefois huawei
arrivé à solutionner ce serait très
compliqué pour toutes les personnes qui
vient d'une autre marque ou qui pour
l'instant utilisent android purement et
simplement avec huawei ou avec au nord
de switcher sur une solution 100% web et
le truc en fait qui ressort c'est que ça
ressemble vraiment une mise en jeu parce
que vous en pensez vous méditant dans un
commentaire il a très clairement le
gouvernement américain ce qu'ils font
c'est qu'ils bloquent tout simplement
huawei en dehors de la chine vue qui
peut pas utiliser android et vu qu'il
peut pas travailler avec des entreprises
américaines pour développer son
smartphone ça sent prêt est relativement
compliquée en tout cas en dehors du
territoire chinois
et qu'est ce que ça montre tout ça ça
monte un truc qui relativement
intéressant c'est la force de frappe
américaine dès lors que le gouvernement
américain impose une interdiction comme
celle là ça va impacter tout un ensemble
d'entreprises comme aujourd'hui android
c'est loes principal je parle même pas
d'apple et d'ailleurs est ce parce que
c'est quand même relativement à part vu
que c'est une entreprise américaine donc
ils vont pas s'auto impact est là dessus
a absolument aucun problème mais vu
google avec android un monopole en
termes d'os les états unis avec ce genre
d'interdiction peuvent très facilement
bloquer tout un marché sans aucun
problème donc aujourd'hui sa frappe
huawei qui peut plus utiliser les
services google mais si demain les
etats-unis ont une quelconque suspicion
envers une autre entreprise chinoise
ils peuvent faire la même chose des
idées tout simplement deux blocs et de
les mettre sur la liste noire et auquel
cas ils pourront plus utiliser aucun
services et produits américains
ce qui est quand même relativement sans
prendre aujourd'hui ce qui est
absolument aucune preuve le gouvernement
américain n'a fourni aucune preuve en
tout cas ya juste des suspicions d'
espionnage mais strictement aucune
preuve d'aucun partant juste sur les
suspicions ils décident de bloquer de
mettre à mort une entreprise on pourrait
voir une ingérence des états unis dans
une espèce de guerre commerciale entre
d'un côté la chine de l'autre côté les
états unis et au delà d'une guerre
commerciale anglais dans une guerre
commerciale technologique là ce que fait
le gouvernement de rome s'est très
clairement de protectionnisme ils sont
en train de nous faire des murs et
construisent des murs on se retrouve
encore avec une espèce de guerre froide
il y met les murs autour d'eux donc
aujourd'hui au web demain peut-être une
autre
on est dans un an
yem ronde je dirai au niveau d'une bière
froide technologique ça semble quand
même relativement compliquée pour
l'avenir et je suis pas sûr que le
gouvernement trophe cherche à faire
machine arrière à venir mais au final ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui ça peut aussi
fragiliser google parce que google a la
mainmise sur les os au niveau des
smartphones et au niveau des tablettes
si demain les autres entreprises se
sentent en tout cas potentiellement en
danger
elles peuvent eux déjà toutes les
entreprises chinoises pourquoi pas se
regrouper en faisant elles mêmes leur
propre os ou alors chaque marque
chaque entreprise fait son propre os on
peut imaginer il ya bien un os sur apple
il pourrait y avoir un webos pour y
avoir un au poète de la même manière
qu'elle est surtout qu'on pourra voir
des os clairement et simplement
fabriqués par les marques et au final
c'est google qui aurait un perdre
puisqu'il aurait tout simplement plus la
mainmise au niveau de l'ouest et
d'android et de leurs services donc on
pourrait très bien imaginer aussi que
des clients migrent ne lie pas forcément
sur gmail mais sur une note types de
boîtes aux lettres numérique utilise un
autre service autre que google maps
n'utilise plus chrome pour naviguer et
quand on sait que le business model de
google se fait par la data ça peut
rapidement aussi in fine être compliqué
pour google parce que ce qu'on voit
c'est que les entreprises américaines
elles ont besoin des entreprises
chinoises ne serait ce que pour se
fournir en maître la première parce que
les usines sont quand même en chine et
d'un côté les chinois ont aussi besoin
des américains ne serait-ce qu'au niveau
des fournisseurs comme qualcomm comme
intel je vous en passe encore et des
meilleurs est également google
on a donc deux pays qui ont besoin l'un
de l'autre pour travailler ensemble sauf
qu'avec une action politique comme ça ça
vient quand même relativement compliqué
alors après je ne dis pas que la chine
allait tout blanchin on est quand même
relativement compliqué d'un point de vue
politique mais néanmoins le
protectionnisme n'avez qu'à comme il est
en train d'être mis en place ne me
paraît pas forcément être bon aller dans
le bon sens je sais pas si huawei fait
de l'espionnage ça j'en absolument pas
de preuve mais en tout cas faute de
preuves ça me semble compliqué que les
américains prennent ces mesures
préventives
qu'est ce que vous pensez tout ça est ce
que vous pensez que les mesures qui sont
prises par gouvernement américain sont
plutôt bien qu'ils aient c'est une
mesure préventive est ce que vous pensez
que ça va dans le bon sens ou alors
qu'au contraire c'est absolument
n'importe quoi dit pas ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires
maintenant on va suivre ça de près
qu'est ce qui va se passer au niveau des
marques qu'est-ce que huawei va faire je
pense pas qu'on relâche la faire à
qu'est-ce que vous avez va faire comment
est-ce que huawei va réagir comment
est-ce que d'autres grandes marques dont
ceux
prémunir de ce qui se passe en tout cas
du point de vue américain comment est ce
que google va réagir ya vraiment
intéressant et avoir plein de ce soir là
dessus donc je vous invite à faire une
chose bien évidemment c'est à vous
abonner comme ça on suivra ça ensemble
on en reparlera mais pour l'instant on
va aussi se concentrer sur plein de
produits intéressants de huawei et de
honor rien d'autre à tester qui sont
couleur ils sont sortis donc pour
l'instant rassurez vous si vous les
achetez vous aurez pas de souci pour
utiliser les services google pour les
mises à jour donc ça ça devrait quand
même pas trop mal se passer
dites moi bien évidemment ce que vous
pensez tout ça en bas en commentaire
donne rendez vous dès demain